The world's second largest
economy had a tough year in 2023.
Now one of Beijing's answers
to the challenge
ban and erase criticism of it.
In December,
China's Ministry of State
Security issued this order resolutely
crack down and punish
illegal criminal activities
that endanger
national security
in the economic security field.
Apparently, that includes disappearing
negative commentary
from the already heavily
censored Chinese Internet.
So is she even bothered
to read those orders on December 1st?
This prominent economic
professor, Yuji Ping,
advised people
not to invest in the falling
Chinese stock market.
Now, all of Professor Liu's social media
accounts are frozen
and when you click to follow him,
you get this message,
which translates
It is forbidden to follow this user
due to their violation of relevant rules.
CNN found
similar freezes temporarily imposed on
at least five other Chinese
economic analysts
also removed from the Internet.
Saw this documentary highlighting
economic hardship
among Chinese migrant workers.
I think the Chinese economy
is at a cliff edge at the moment.
I don't think
it has not fallen off the cliff yet,
but it's getting to a point
where things can get much more difficult.
Officially,
the Chinese economy grew
by more than 5% last year,
but the country's youth unemployment
rate keeps hitting record highs.
Then there's China's
all important
real estate sector,
which along with related industries, used
to make up 30% of the Chinese economy.
This is the Hong Kong office
of the biggest symbol of China's
real estate crisis, Evergrande.
Until two years ago,
this company
was the largest homebuilder in China,
employing some 200,000 people.
Then the company defaulted on its debt
and now a court here in Hong
Kong has ordered the liquidation
of Evergrande.
Across the
country, protests as angry new homebuyers
demand completion of unfinished homes
that they've already paid for.
Perhaps the only other sector gloomier
is the country's stock market.
In the past three years,
the combined
Chinese stock market
lost more than $6 trillion.
To show you me,
I haven't made any money
out of the stock market,
so I sold all my stocks.
If you don't sell,
I hope
the Chinese economy is strong
and it will be stronger,
says this Beijing resident.
Perhaps she got the message
from this recent meeting of the country's
top propaganda officials.
Their order
amplify bright prospects of the economy.
As China heads into 2024.
All you know
so before I bring Ivan in,
I want to show you
CNN's feed of this program
as it's being seen in China
or more accurately,
at what Chinese censors replaced it with.
As soon as we mentioned the story
that you just saw again.
Color bars there, it's not going out.
So, Ivan,
if China is censoring economists
and CNN's reporting about it
and most of their economic
data is released,
it comes from the Chinese government.
How hard is it to get a true picture
of the state of the Chinese economy?
Well, it's a big question.
It's long
been a big question
for economists and investors.
The reliability of these numbers,
especially back in August
when the government announced
it would stop publishing youth
unemployment numbers
after several months of record highs,
the mood has changed a lot.
You know, foreign companies,
they used to line up to try
to get access to the huge Chinese market.
Last year, for the first time
in 25 years, John.
Foreign direct investment into China
went into the negative.
That means foreign companies
appeared to be pulling out more money
than they were investing
into their corporations,
into their operations.
Companies like Vanguard
that asset management company telling CNN
it was selling its stake
and closing its office in Shanghai
at the end of last year.
So the Chinese government,
it's got a long way
to go to rebuild its credibility
with international corporations
and also, I'd argue,
with ordinary Chinese consumers.
And I'm not sure that censorship
and ordering officials
to paint rosy pictures about the economy,
that that's a winning strategy
to build consumer confidence
in an economy
that clearly has some big problems.
Ivan, revealing report there.
Thank you very much.